[Applause]
one of my favorite movies of all time is
coming to america
coming to america too is um
is here and we can all finally go back
to zamunda
was there a moment where you said now is
the right time to make this sequel
no it kind of happened organically this
movie the way it came together because
the way the story ended
it was kind of like that it was and they
lived happily ever after
and we didn't even think about making a
sequel but then the movie came like a
cult movie like little stuff from the
movie just stayed around
of all the movies that i've done none of
them no movie is on tv as much as coming
to america it's always
on and little lines from the movie
people are sexual chocolate
people say it had a little line from the
movie or the mic drop that everybody
does the the mic drop
the very first mic drop ever is randy
watson from coming to america
all this all this little stuff from the
movie and then what happened
about 10 years ago uh people started
some people on halloween would dress up
as the characters and
there's a restaurant in la that on
halloween it
changes itself into mcdowell's and they
have like a mcdowell's menu so
it really is like this like cult movie
so uh
it became that and that's when i started
having the idea
but you know the people that really
really like that movie might you know
want to see a sequel to it and then we
when we figured out a way to connect the
dots and then
to make it make sense then we wrote
wrote a script and it came together
right can i ask um
a burning question that i've wondered
ever since i first saw the movie which
is the little child on the skateboard
because they've all taken
the suitcases um and they're wearing all
the fabulous the munda garb
was it like let's just say that we have
so much clothes that they're our child
sizes or screw it
tailor it funnier we're taking license
there
because i know it's a kid and he has a
little
a child side you have to remember now
that
the movie was a comedy and it was
directed by the great john landis
john lennon there was a people uh when
they talk about coming to america when
i'm asked about coming to america they
get
me and arsenio like the actors that get
all the credit for the movie and that
movie
is that movie is more john landis than
anything
and that's a john landis joke to have
the kids go skating by
and at the end and the moment he
probably was like hey have a kids
skateboard
he's like that it's my favorite moment
other than of course
the quote of i have a date with lisa
and it's um i say it every day because
it's my version of showing that i'm
happy
that's wonderful you know that scene
right there
at uh the little girls that are in that
scene
uh was a friend of mine named named
jeffrey moore who
lived in brooklyn and he stopped by the
set that day and the little girl
in the in the light blue jacket that was
his daughter she was just with him we
just put her in the scene like right
there
it just happened at that moment would
you ever say it with me
will you say it with me how could i say
it like this
i have a david lease
[Applause]
around out and did it the first time
[Laughter]
eddie i i'm so happy to see you
thank you for giving me such incredible
salient life advice
it's nice to see you too and i look
forward to after all this uh
pandemic stuff is over come there and
see live in person
i will roll myself up in this carpet for
you i'll be like a burrito
by the time we finish and i will dance
that victory dance
and um recognize the purpose
and and if you don't do it physically do
it you know
get ready to always start the day with
i've already won this at this
game i've already won now it's just
about you know
getting the most out of everything you
know being here
and your your babies and your family i i
very much recognize that and i
i love it coming from the person who has
made
life make sense for so many of us
on this planet by helping us love and
laugh
and enjoy life and fall in love with the
extraordinary characters
that are you that you've put out into
the world thank you
coming to america is now available
globally
on prime video
you